hey duck how you doing tucker how you
doing bud
he's such a good boy talker you see war
in such a good mood today
hey what's up garden friends jeff here
trump i'm stuck why am i stuck jeffrey
tropical plant party has everybody doing
hope you're good i'm great i am getting
ready to work on my drip you think this
is for you
i think everything's for you it's not
for you yeah i have
an extra zone left on my timers
i'll show you all this when i get to it
and i thought it would be a good idea to
use that zone to run to the ostrich
ferns that got planted in the
the shade garden not too terribly long
ago so i'm going through my basket here
sorting pieces out i'm going to need
this this is what you use to attach the
half inch drip line to the timers or to
your faucet whatever you're using
i don't have any strainers or anything
like that but i'm not on
well water so i don't really need to
worry about that i have tons of teas
do you guys anybody else have their huge
drip i always use tons and tons of teas
gonna need the punch tool
this is necessary in order to make the
connections to the lines
and then i need to find where is it i
have my drip heads here these are
adjustable drip heads and the only thing
i'm missing are the adapters which are
really
really important here we go quarter inch
couplers i'm going to need more than
four so i'm gonna go do some digging
and then maybe you can hang out while i
get this drip set up oh and i need
clamps
i'll talk about why all this matters
here in just a second toby you haven't
said hi yet say hello toby
all right okay that's enough now i had a
bunch of stuff that i was getting ready
to plant up but
i realized i haven't really talked about
drip
on the channel before i've like talked
about how i have things on drip
but never really the process or what i
do with it so i thought that would be a
good thing to
vlog so last night i went ahead and i
took the half inch tubing
and i stretched it out i went and i put
it around the base of this palm tree and
then i pulled it all the way over there
as you can see it's coiled very tightly
as you undo it it just looks like a big
spring so i went ahead and i did that
pulled out way more than i need to use
right now
but that's okay i'd rather have too much
over
too little that's for sure i'm gonna go
ahead and make my cuts get the right
length and then get that new sprinkler
zone set up
all right so i've got a line run goes
all the way back here behind the grill
then it comes around the front goes
behind the maple
and i have it basically running so it's
right in front of all these different
ferns i've got my length
just about how i need it can you see you
see this look at them
i mean they look better than they did
before they have new growth but the
sprinklers just don't hit over here
and since these are newly transplanted
just seems smart to go ahead and get
them on to drip
that way they'll establish well and i
don't have to mess with them anymore
it's a pain getting my garden hose over
here so over here is my little
area that's just a disaster i'm redoing
my drip system
completely next year so i'm not going to
go
too crazy here with what i'm doing i
just don't think that that would be
smart
but for the time being just since i
can't spend a lot of time
out in the heat or in the sun watering
that'll be different next year but for
right now
this is just going to have to do so i
have two different timers here
and this one has an extra zone on it so
does that one
this timer runs on bluetooth which is
kind of nifty so i can just take my
phone out make any adjustments that i
need to
i can't wait to get all this pottery
over here cleaned up i finally have an
area set up to store all my extra
pottery
so i'm gonna be able to get this whole
area cleaned up i cannot wait to do that
this is a hose end adapter pretty simple
to use you just
push this end in this piece screws down
and then
this piece right here screw that end
right on here you can see i've already
put some plumbers tape on here
these things tend to they leak like
crazy
make sure that this is on there nice and
tight
don't want there to be any slack don't
want to be on crooked
sometimes i have to come through and
make adjustments and see one of these is
dripping there's a puddle here that's
not supposed to be there so i'm gonna
have to check on that in just a minute
now we put a clamp on the end and here's
that
clamp this is very simple drip is very
very easy
slide it down on one end make a bend so
that there's at least
three inches that's probably too much
doesn't need to be that much but it's
not going to hurt to have too much
and then you just slide that up there
and that's it that's how you end the
line right there
so simple now i'm going to tap into it
add my drip heads and this will be done
and to actually get it set up so that it
functions as drip this is where the
punch tool
comes in necessary you can see this tool
here if it will focus come on now
has a spiky end on it just fits around
the hose push down really hard
that'll stamp a hole into it pull it out
and you take these couplers right here
with this punch tool you just snap those
couplers right into the end
this makes it so much easier so you can
just use the punch tool to push that in
there
that'll lock that right into place just
how it needs to be then i take my
quarter inch tubing right here this fits
right onto the top of that coupler
just like so and then i put an
adjustable drip head
on the end of that does not want to
focus i like the adjustable
drip heads a lot just because well
they're adjustable
i don't have to be too specific with
making sure i'm using the right ones
with these
and you can see i put that out nice and
low because i don't want the water
shooting into the crown of that fern
and i'm going to go ahead and do that
down this entire length and that's it
done pretty simple main thing usually
you want to make sure that you keep the
drip heads where they're punched into
the half inch
generally you don't want them any closer
than about eight inches to a foot that's
just
best for pressure i've had them closer
together than that before and it wasn't
an issue
and then i'm just gonna kind of play
around with the settings on because you
got to twist the tops on those to make
sure the flow's right and
that's it see simple so easy all right
so i actually i went ahead and i moved
the line from here to over there because
this isn't working talk more about that
in a minute i think melnor jumped the
gun with these bluetooth timers
i have it set up over here so i'm going
to run it manually
real quick which is sometimes a little
bit
tricky for me to remember how to do
there we go one two three
do five minutes make sure it turns on
wait for the click
okay hit it okay first there we go
there's the click
yes see so see that that's why i
got to go through and check them looks
like there are
at least one of these that didn't hold
on
very well this tubing is kind of
flexible too i got like discount tubing
usually it's more firm so this is
probably going to be a
theme for all of these so i might switch
out the tubing at some point but
that's the point testing it out so i'll
reattach that i have these set to
run like high they are on very high
right now because i need to
saturate the area it's pretty dry but
right now i'm going to have these set to
run
three times a day early morning early
afternoon and then just a little bit
later than that just to really make sure
this whole area gets
saturated because the soil dries and
drains very quickly
and just for right now probably for the
next probably two to three weeks i'll
keep them running every single day
unless it rains and then i'll shut them
up
that's just because i really need to get
these ferns established and then i'll
probably dial it back to every other day
i would like to turn them down just a
little bit so you can see that it looks
like it's not running
but it is it's just coming off the end
of the stake so
they don't need to be up quite this high
when i wasn't looking through the
viewfinder i realized that they were up
a little bit too high but like i said i
do want to make sure they're getting
heavily watered so i might just
let it be that way just for a couple of
days all right so that was one
very simple way of doing things with the
half inch line i like using half inch
line the thicker hose because you just
get more water pressure
you don't have to do things that way
those with smaller applications see this
right here
this is a hose end fitting for quarter
inch tubing so you don't have to use one
of those big thick lines
and this works really well i've used
these on many other things i even think
i have a couple of these still set up
for areas where i only needed a few drip
heads
and it's it works well but with those
you're going to need a lot of these tees
it's kind of like putting together a
puzzle working with drip in general
is sort of a puzzle which is kind of fun
it gets frustrating
for me but that's usually just dealing
with the timers because i haven't found
a brand that's like fully reliable
i've been using them for many years but
over here i have kind of an example of
what i was talking about with this
puzzle actually i'll turn these on so
you can see a little bit better yeah at
one point
not too long ago i had one of those
bluetooth timers over here too
and uh broke stopped working luckily
i had one of these laying around this
one though
has been giving me a little bit of
trouble but it looks like today it's
decided to work so i don't really know
what that's about
so this is the zone i have set up for
basically this entire bed and some pots
i'll walk you around with that once i
get this turned on there we go so this
is my
zone two it goes pretty much mostly to
this alexander palm in a few other areas
you see all these heads in here
i have them all set up onto one line
right there with the t
in it and that t goes down to one of
these half inch lines
down there by my feet which look funny
throw squished up just that one line i
was able to come through
make a connection make another
connection
and then make another connection until i
have full circle
of these in here because this is a
really big palm tree but this is what i
was talking about
about having to sort of do your own
little puzzles that way
i actually think it's more time
consuming to use the faucet adapters
that run off the quarter inch tubing
but it's each their own you know maybe
you only have a few plants you need to
get set up
and then that works just fine but for
larger applications
it's not always the most practical and
this wasn't
hard to do it wasn't hard getting all
these set up like this but
it just seems so much easier to just pop
a line down into that half inch hosing
but for something like this
it was necessary and even my pool pots
which don't look good
because i told you that other timer
broke and by the time i figured it out
it's too late for some of the plants
unfortunately
but same thing this line right here runs
over there
i have another head around on that side
i have two running on this mule palm
two on that one and then a beige line
that's very hard to see it runs over
there and taps into the half inch tubing
now i wouldn't do this if i had children
around or just anybody who might trip on
it but i mean
that's not something i have to worry
about ideally there would be a water
line tapped in right there but
champagne wishes i just don't think
that's necessary and i could also just
not have a wine on here and hand water
but i'm not supposed to be out in the
heat y'all know what's going on the
health thing so
that's why those are set up like that
why was i showing you the one where the
timer had broken the plants look
terrible here's a better example
drip it's amazing isn't it these plants
look great and there's the head in there
this one i believe
both of these edinity palms this one
this one over here
should both have three heads in these
pots
yeah there's one right there another one
right here and then one that wraps
around that other side
it's a lot but they're sitting out in
the sun almost tripped
they're sitting out in the sun and this
pavement dark
gets hot i mean you can see it's a
pretty effective
works really well this doesn't mean that
i don't hand water still when it gets
really hot out i still come out
make sure that these get a drink even
with the drip because sometimes with
drip
you'll end up just having zones that are
moist instead of having even moisture
all the way around the reason we use
drip one is just easier it's less time
watering
and then you have water moving directly
towards the roots
of the plants because that one visible
right here
kind of visible you sort of see it so
that water is going right onto the soil
and then right down to the roots
you're not getting moisture all over the
foliage now where i live
that's not really a problem there are
usually issues with fungus and
whatnot if the foliage gets wet at night
time but
it's still nice because you can use less
water and have more effective watering
that way just want to make sure that you
haven't set to run long enough so that
the plants are being watered
thoroughly and that it's not just a
light watering so you get shallow root
development
and weird wonky-looking plants and that
kind of heats the purpose right
once upon a time i had my drip also set
up to a fertilizing system and that was
amazing i spent two and a half hours
fertilizing today
that's too long that's that i don't want
to keep doing that but i want to
fertilize once a week because i haven't
really
like i said before you know what's been
going on out here i've really been able
to take care of things so i'd like to go
ahead and
since there's like i don't know five
weeks left that i can fertilize out here
before
i need to back off because of the fall
temperatures it just makes sense to get
on that
now and make the most of what i can with
the plants so my point there was you can
hook
fertilizer injection systems up to these
as well
good idea to make sure you have a
strainer i don't have any strainers
they're like little screens and it's a
good idea to use them i just don't have
any
the screen that goes in between the male
end
of your timer or faucet whatever you're
using and then this piece right here
that just keeps debris minerals and
things like that from getting into your
lines and then clogging up your drip
emitters
i have been asked to do videos on my
drip before and i've never done it
largely just because
i know i'm gonna get the same question
over and over and over again which is
how do i set up my timers and how often
do i water it
i don't know i i couldn't tell you it
depends on where you live depends on
your soil depends what kind of plants
you have um
it's that's a little bit more of a
tricky side to this
sometimes i found i'd have to kind of
play around with getting the timer set
up
and seeing how the plants are doing i
usually start off low
so they're not getting watered for very
long and not too terribly often see how
they do
and then i bump it up from there if
necessary which it usually is in st
louis missouri it gets very hot here
during the summer it's been unusually
cool here the past few days which has
been nice but
typically july june july august and
september are
pretty toasty 90s and lower hundreds
with a good amount of humidity
so a lot of watering is necessary hence
the drip and i was trying to think if
there were any other
parts that i would recommend always
making sure you have on hand if you're
setting up drips or
couplers very necessary especially if
you're tapping into a half inch line
then
it's not it's a necessity you have to
have those punch tool i like punch tools
that will make the hole
and that you can snap the adapter in
that piece we just talked about so you
just pop it right in i already showed
you that
makes it so much easier a good punch
tool does make a big difference
something to cut your lines
also nifty to have around oh and then
after a thought
this half inch tubing it's not very
forgiving it doesn't flex well
and once it has a bend or a kink in it
it's usually there forever it's really
hard to get it out so it's nifty to have
couplers on hand these couplers you just
make a cut you get the kink out and then
you rejoin the tubing together
that's very nifty so it's always a good
idea usually to have a couple of these
laying around if you have
a lot of angles you're working with
where it might get kinked or to actually
have like 90 degree angle
couplers which they do make i don't have
any to show right now
but that way you can get your half inch
tubing
to that way you can get your half inch
tubing to go around sharper angles and
stuff like that because like i said it
doesn't have
any forgiveness it doesn't bend well so
those are also important things that i
kind of i left out
that i'm actually i forgot to mention
that i'm editing see all the editing
stuff going on here oops that's one to
make sure i remember to include that in
the video because it is important these
things they kink
very easily and then here they are goof
plugs see that
goof plugs so sometimes you make a hole
in the wrong spot
on those half inch lines or maybe you
have to move an adapter
that's when you use these they've gotten
kind of dirty they've been sitting out
but it's just
a little plug it's just like it sounds
so if you mess up then you can just pop
that
in place of that hole so you just have
like a geyser water shooting out of your
tubing
those are good to have around and then
the t's i always have tons of tees
around because i'm always having to
find different areas i need to run a new
drip off of now i'm
actually uh i'm not gonna say relieved
that i realize that the
other timer is broken this is actually a
new one looks just like that other one
i don't think i'm gonna set it up though
because this this is a replacement to
the one that was over by the
alexander palm that broke and now the
other one's broken
so i think i'd rather just send these
back and not have to keep messing with
that i have been
really confused as to why these
colocasias have been so
incredibly thirsty and it's be the
drip's not running on them
and i was gonna check that and i hadn't
gotten around to it but now i know for
sure that that's
not an issue i need to worry about i was
going to run a whole nother drip line
back behind all of these plants and it
just it wouldn't have been fun it's not
something i wanted to do
actually i guess i am i guess i could
say relieved to just know that i just
need to put a new timer on that zone
although it'd be a lot easier to run a
different drip line then i also was
going to talk about why i like the
variable drip heads this is a better
representation
of that the adjustable dripper stakes
you see it you see it
you know what i'm talking about you've
been looking at them this entire video
the downside to these has
always been that they're kind of pricey
this little three pack right here from
the big box stores like five six
bucks that's a lot of money they come
with a
adapter on them which is nice it just
snaps right off of them so you can
pop it right in but that doesn't make up
for the cost
however on amazon you can get a pack of
50 for 9.99
i will say some of them didn't have the
little adjustable heads on them which
makes them kind of useless but i have
extras of those so
it's okay that's the only thing about
these adjustable heads that i
don't like is the cost but that makes up
for it right there
otherwise usually people would use i
used to use
just emitters you hook to a little stake
and it just kind of dangles over the
plant
and they range from like a quarter of a
gallon a half a gallon a gallon
of water per hour something like that
the reason
i don't use those anymore is because i
have so
many different timers set up as it is
right now i have 14 different zones
and if i end up with an area that is
being underwatered say we have a heat
spell or something like that
with 14 different zones running they
can't run at the same time because i
don't have enough water pressure
so i have to have a little bit of leeway
i try and space each zone out by five
minutes apart so
this one runs it from seven to seven oh
five then i'll set
zone two to run at seven ten so there's
like a five minute gap
in case i need to increase the time but
with those regular drip heads you
have to bump the time up if they're not
performing well enough or switch to a
different head
so if i needed more water in an area i
would have to increase
zone one by like another five to ten
minutes or something like that
and that just becomes cumbersome when
you're working with 14 different zones
it's it's too much it's kind of a
headache so that's why i like the
adjustable heads because then i can just
twist them and they'll let out more
water for the duration
or if we're having a wet spell that i
can go through and well if we're having
a wet spell i'll probably just set the
timers to be off
and there are rain sensors you can put
on these too which is nifty
i haven't messed with any of those
because i keep having to replace my
timers because i can't find timers it'll
last a long time
i've mostly just used melnor in orbit
and uh
the thing with melnor even though i'm
not having good luck with these timers
which is a shame because i was really
looking forward to doing a video on
these bluetooth timers when i first set
them up
i was so excited about them like i said
they jumped the gun they're not ready
the
software was glitchy it was neat because
you could set like pictures to each zone
which was fun
because it just made it easier really
but the issue was like
if i had zone one set for like my
gingers i take a picture of my gingers
and then i'd run zone one
then i'd open up the app and it would
say that zone two is running
when it's not zone one's running but
that it would show that the
like that it just it wasn't working well
and now just in general
these things keep breaking so it's not
there yet but there are other bluetooth
timers out there there's lots of other
brands of timers out there
this is just what i've been working with
but the thing i most about melnor is
whenever i've had
issues with their timers over the years
i've called them and they've sent me
replacements and their customer service
has always been really great this isn't
sponsored just saying that's been my
experience so that's just
where all that stands there's all the
drip stuff this isn't all of my drip
stuff that was just a rundown on me and
my drip systems i have tons of drip
supplies over the years you build up i
have
like little tool boxes for them i have
entire giant
totes like you know the big big like
storage totes just
overflowing with drip supplies somehow i
always end up having to run to the store
because there's like just one part i
don't have
which is usually more of an issue with
the micro
misters or the micro irrigation stakes
let's talk about those now
micro sprayers these little
jets right here i'm really more
referring to the stake
right here and then the different
emitters you can put on them right now
this has a 360 i believe is what it's
called
so it will put out lots of streams of
water that come down from it
put that in there so you can see i'm
talking about so they come
down and it will broadcast more evenly
to the plants as opposed to
fanning out the ones that fan out are
really nifty
these types of emitters these usually
have an adjustable knob on them so you
can adjust the flow rate the different
heads are very easy to change they just
screw and unscrew from this collar right
here a little bit more pricey
i mean they're like a few bucks a pop
but these are great
if you have to water a larger area you
know you saw
how big the fan spray was on those
adjustable heads this is more for if you
have big garden beds or something like
that
really nifty for larger areas and here's
like
an example package of just like assorted
heads
that so you can get like 165 180 320 fan
sprays
that's nice because sometimes you have
an area where you don't
want everything watered or maybe you
have like a sidewalk or something like
that
so you wouldn't want a circle spinner on
it and i don't think i have any
circle spinners as i was just talking
about how i have so many things
i run out of the circle spinners locks
they use a lot of them there are large
ones and small ones
and it's just like it says it'll do a
fan
a big fan area and water everything
within that
circular area that's just another way to
go with drip
i use both i use a little bit of
everything really
hey tobes how you doing toby so as far
as the timers are concerned
i know i've already talked about these a
whole bunch but just in general
i do i don't know where it went hence
part of the problem right now
but i do have a plastic tote with holes
cut along the side for ventilation that
i try to keep over these so that they
don't get drenched with water when it
rains
and to help keep the sun off of them i
remove them in the winter time
also depending on where you live in the
winter time it is usually a good idea to
blow these lines out with like an air
compressor
this probably won't come as a shocker to
anybody but i've never done that and
i've never had a problem
but i make sure that all those heads i
use are wide open
when i get these shut off and i get the
lines off the timers and have everything
pulled apart so essentially they're not
blown
out but there's room basically for water
to expand should things freeze
yeah it's good to keep them from being
exposed to the elements i know
this looks like a mess but it's a lot
there's a lot going on here
i'm pretty sure as soon as i'm done
recording this i'll think of
lots of other things that i should have
mentioned about the drip irrigation
i just kind of wanted to do a rundown on
what i do setting up that new zone
and like i said that zone setup extreme
i'm not always going to have them open
those drippers open that wide to keep
things drenched that's just
for a few weeks to get those ferns
established and before things are
starting to warm up so
they need that right now but otherwise
that's kind of the rundown in the gist
of things i am going to get a
new timer get that zone over there fixed
and i am looking at getting a new
fertilizer
injector to set into these systems
because like i said two and a half hours
it's a long time to fertilize and i had
to refill my little handheld thing
six times too much took too long i have
been doing it for this long so in a
while the sudden i've decided that i
don't want to
do it by hand anymore but for the brief
period of time
when i had an injector it's like a
bottle that
hooked into everything and had a line
that ran through it that was really
nifty and i miss it but they're just
they're kind of pricey the one i had was
really cheap
so it didn't last very long if i get
another one i want to go with one a
little bit nicer like one of the
dosatronics one of those sorts of things
so
wow there it is i was going to plant up
some things in this video but
it's already long enough so maybe
there'll be another midweek vlog
like i did last week we will see or i'll
just do it next week
i don't know but everything's looking
pretty good out here the plants are nice
and happy and healthy with the exception
of the annuals like you saw before that
i haven't gotten planted yet which i
have
mostly rounded up got into the gorilla
cart i'm gonna throw together some
hanging baskets and just start tucking
these away i'll thumb the process it's
not gonna be anything mind-blowing
because the plants are
and they look terrible i got them back
in march and april and they're still in
their little nursery cans they look
horrible
but it'll be fun to get those planted up
and i
think that should be everything like i
said i'm sure i'll think of more things
it's what the comment sections for
though comment down below
any tips tricks suggestions what are
some things you do with your drip
systems
i think it's really great that and the
nice thing about youtube is that
people can make these videos make these
plant videos and then
sometimes hopefully if something doesn't
get covered somebody might mention it
down in the comments
so like things just keep going so you
have more information to feed off of we
can all kind of
build on things together don't you get
in there it's almost time to go in the
house you better not
oh yeah help keep up the info comment
down below
tips tricks suggestions always
appreciated reliable
brands of timers let me know like i said
the melnor thing not working out for me
this year but i've used them for a long
time
haven't had issues until this year with
these new bluetooth timers and their
customer service has been pretty great
they've also used orbit and their timers
worked really well too it's going to do
it though
my battery's dying so i hope everybody's
doing well having a great day a great
life
and everything's just going beautifully
for you again like i had mentioned
comment down below
tips tricks suggestions with the drip
irrigation it's always nifty to have
that extra input you can see right here
i have a sprayer
this is a wide area one thing i didn't
mention is make sure that that's not
going to spray into the crowns of plants
and rot them
i should have said that that's that's
important don't write your plants out
ah my social media is linked down below
i use
instagram way more than anything else
really that's pretty much all i use
these days pretty much
just instagram look at how the sun's
hitting these hydrangea flowers
so pretty they're basically glowing it's
time to go what you're looking for tobes
what you looking for come here come on
don't just stand there
wrong way what is wrong with you come on
toby where is he where is he it's over
toby
yeah which were you confused why do you
take the longest wipe you ran all the
way down there when you could have just
come
dogs alright as always and most
importantly everybody
keep on growing bye
[Applause]
you